hey guys it's the friday show which
means I've got all the good news and
none of the boring crap here's one that
is this week
Sony Online Entertainment broke out on
its own this week and is no longer owned
by Sony this isn't quite the end of days
result for Sony that some are making it
out to be but it does mean ah so we can
make games for xbox now which they're
pretty pumped about SOA who is now
rebranding as daybreak a game company is
responsible for pc and ps4 MMOs like
EverQuest next planetside 2 h 1 set 1
and DC Universe Online the company have
confirmed that it's business as usual
regardless of the buyout and the main
change will be further embracing
multi-platform gaming Destiny's upcoming
house of wolves DLC sprung a mighty leak
this week as we found out a bunch of
details about it before Bungie wanted us
to it has read it the leak stated that
the release date would be May nineteen
and bungie themselves have now confirmed
that release window promising it'll see
the light of day sometime in the second
quarter of 2015 so from april to june
Bungie didn't give us any more official
information about House of wolves but if
your canes are unofficial data mined
info loaded with screenshots you can
check out that story on gamespot Bungie
also revealed that something destiny
related is coming this fall but we have
no idea what it is yet so moving on now
the middle bit of my friday news section
which I've decided to dedicate to
helping you find game things that are
cheap because spending money is the
worst nintendo have been pissing off
youtubers this week with their wildly
uncool policy to take creators money for
streaming their games then giving it
back but not all of it then taking it
away again if you play the wrong game
anyway at the same time Nintendo's
loyalty program club nintendo has
officially begun shutting down which is
a bit sad but with it comes big
discounts on a variety of gear and
digital game downloads for Wii U and
sweet
if you've already collected a bunch of
coins using the program that is if you
want an int understand humble bundle
will give you nine star wars games for
12 bucks which should tide you over
until battlefront comes out this year
also Knights of the Old Republic is in
there so you shouldn't need any more
reason to check this one out then back
till date ladies worried about super
intelligent robot overlord and I don't
know about you but if Bill Gates said
he's worried I'm gonna get on board as
part of his reddit AMA from a week ago
he talked about the hypothetical future
of robots helping pick fruit as just the
beginning and after that we need to
worry about them getting smarter he said
he doesn't understand why people aren't
concerned about machines becoming super
intelligent and he's on board with Tesla
founder Elon Musk who said these AI
systems are potentially more dangerous
than nukes and veneers of things that
won't keep you lying awake at night
listening out the threatening bleep
robot noises call of duty 2015 has been
confirmed the mammoth franchise is
getting a new entry from treyarch who
worked on the black ops games activision
announced that we're going to see the
game sometime this fall probably at the
same time it always comes out although
they wouldn't confirm if the game is
going to be another title in the black
ops series or not this is set to be the
first of trey arcs call of duty
contributions to feature since
Activision started their new 3 here for
a studio development schedule let me
know down in the comments which call of
duty game is your favorite or if you are
the fan of the franchise and why this
week on site I asked if we should stop
pre-ordering games on the chest cam
compares the oculus rift to microsoft
hololens and Skyrim log gets into some
new martial arts moves those are all the
things that I have been this week be
sure to let me know what you cared about
as always and I'll capture we get on
I